In this lesson, we are going to continue using the lowest common denominator to
help us simplify expressions. The lowest common denominator or LCD has
tremendous power. We're going to use it again to help us simplify complex
fractions. A fraction like this one. I'll guide you through the questions you
want to ask yourself to simplify a fraction like this. To get started, we want
to find the lowest common denominator of all the internal fractions of our
complex fraction. Complex fractions, like this one, have fractions either in the
numerator or in the denominator, or in this case, both. So, let's start our path
to try and simplify this crazy looking thing. What do you think is the LCD for
the denominators x, 4, and 8. Write your answer here.